the most iconic 70s haircut of all time
childhood Fame heartfelt tributes Adam
Rich best remembered as Nicholas
Bradford in the ABC sitcom Eight is
Enough has died TMZ confirms that the
actor died in his Los Angeles home on
January 7 2023. the outlet notes that
his family has not revealed the actor's
cause of death the law enforcement have
ruled out the possibility of Foul Play
Rich was 54. Nicholas stands out as one
of the most popular characters from
Eight is Enough which dominated the
airwaves when it first debuted in the
late 70s the ABC sitcom which ran for
Five Seasons and produced over 100
episodes followed the ups and downs of
the Bradford family which boasted eight
children Nicholas became a fan favorite
as the youngest member of the Bradford
family known for his naivety in the
early episodes Nicholas grew up as the
series progressed with the youngest
member of the Bradford Clan finding
himself in several amusing and heartfelt
situations through his Eight is Enough
character rich is perhaps best known for
popularizing the page boy haircut which
rose in popularity following the
premiere of the ABC sitcom one Reddit
user wrote the most 1970s haircut of all
time Farrah Fawcett gets all the glory
but nope the Adam Rich was rocked by
millions more the series also starred
Dick Van Patton as his father Thomas and
Diana Hyland as his mother Joan Cobra
Kai star Ralph Macchio and La law actor
Michelle Greene also guest starred on
the series Rich alongside most of the
Eight is Enough cast were returned to
their roles for two TV films a family
reunion and an Eight is Enough wedding
ABC called it curtains on Eight Is
Enough in 1981. following the show's
cancellation Rich went on to appear in
the Network's short-lived action Series
code red with guest appearances on
Fantasy Island and chips Rich's career
and show business continued to Blossom
on the small screen the actors
prominence on the small screen continued
with Rich appearing in several
fire-related Public Safety announcements
the child actor's biggest post Eight is
Enough project was voicing Presto the
magician in the animated Dungeons and
dragon series described by den of geek
as quote one of the most imaginative and
gripping classic geek cartoons the
animated series based on the tabletop
game continues to be occult classic Rich
would later go on to appear in Small
Wonder in an episode of Baywatch his big
screen credits included Bill Cosby's the
devil and Max Devlin the film he
appeared in prior to his big break and
Eight is Enough Rich's former talent
manager Todd TJ Stein noted how the
actors struggled to obtain roles
following Aegis enough Stein wrote on
Twitter I repped at him for a short time
in the 1990s and he was willing and
wanting to work but found it hard to get
roles which was discouraging to him
deadline notes that Adam Rich had a
troubled past with substance abuse in
1989 the actor appeared on Entertainment
Tonight to candidly discuss his health
issues in drug use the star was later
arrested in 1991 for breaking into a
pharmacy to get drugs 22 at the time
Rich was bailed out by his Eight is
Enough on-screen father Dick Van Patten
in 1991 report from the Los Angeles
Times later revealed that he was
arrested for shoplifting after the
pharmacy incident following the news of
Adam Rich's passing several fans took to
social media to mourn the actor's death
in a Twitter post publicist Danny
duraney described rich as quote
America's brother calling him simply a
wonderful guy one Twitter user pointed
out just how iconic the Eight is Enough
star's haircut was they wrote he was so
popular that his hairstyle was a
standard for the little boys in my class
my brother too rich spent the last few
years as a mental health Advocate using
his platform to spread positivity and
resources Rich's final tweet served as a
reminder about the importance of
maintaining one's mental health paying
tribute to the late Stephen twitch boss
who died by suicide in late 2022
[Music]